my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
[Music]
but they stay because all the things
they can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an Easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him this is just a game
I'm talking about absolute
life-and-death stuff the Oasis the
world's most important economic resource
there's nothing less than a war we're
controlling the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came here to escape but I found
something much bigger than just myself
are you willing to fight
helped us save the oysters
hey everybody they dropped a new ready
player one trailer let's break this down
this is like an Easter egg hunt to end
all Easter egg hunts they're searching
for an easter egg within the Oasis but
we as viewers are searching for crazy
numbers of Easter eggs and all these
characters that they've used so before
we ever talk about story just general
rule of thumb for character Easter eggs
is that they're generally including
stuff from all Warner Brothers IP which
means a lot of DC characters like Harley
Quinn and the Joker there's some
overwatch characters there's chun-li
from the Street Fighter series
there's the Iron Giant probably my
favorite Easter Egg the DeLorean from
the Back to the Future movies which
isn't Warner Brothers IP that's from
Universal but it is from Steven
Spielberg so there is a little bit of
studio crossover when it's important for
the story because specifically Ernst
Klein wrote the DeLorean into the series
so they would have to go for that and
Steven Spielberg has that kind of juice
that he can go to other studios and say
we want to put your thing in our movie
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's also a bunch of Star
Wars stuff that's coming next week that
I'll explain too but let's just go
through this and try to find all the
characters but if you're not super
familiar with the book story the ioi of
this basically the Ben Mendelsohn
organization they're the villains of the
series they're trying to control what
you would think of as the free internet
so this is big net neutrality argument
that's going on right now in real life
but that's also going on within this
story here so interestingly enough some
of the bigger ideas of the movie are
more relevant today than ever I don't
know if they planned it that way or if
it just ended up being coincidence but
it was also a big argument that was
going on back around the release of the
book in 2010 and 2011 so if you think
the ioi is familiar that's sort of an
easter egg for AOL online the big
corporate entity that wants to control
and monetize the internet so when the
idea of the easter egg is announced like
hey there's a special easter egg it'll
give you half a trillion dollars in
complete control of what they think of
is this special internet place so Ben
Mendelsohn's character in the
corporation is like we have to find this
so that we can make more money then on
the other side of that you have all the
people that are buying for it because
hey who doesn't want a trillion dollars
in control of this really awesome place
but the whole idea is that so to
position these people against the
corporation so even though you have all
these kids in these online tournaments
all the time getting really nasty trying
to beat each other really the idea is is
that it's them against the corporation
so that's where percival runs into a lot
of friends that helped him out along the
way
so you see couple Easter eggs for those
characters throughout the trailer the
red head that he runs into early in the
trailer is one of his competitors but
they also develop a bit of a
relationship you can kind of see over
the course of the trailer with in the
Oasis her avatars name is Artemis she's
the goddess of the hunt
she's also hunting for the Easter egg so
there's a little bit of conflict between
the two of them but like I said it's
them against the corporation so that's
why you see them in real life running
from all these ioi people that are
chasing them down so like you see
someone hand him this bronze key here
that's like the first key in the stage
of this Easter egg hunt it's when he
gains notoriety it's when he runs into
the Artemis character when he starts
gaining online sponsors and his life
starts getting better so he gets swept
up in this big world but it's just a
series of stages that you unlock on your
way to the easter egg so things get
crazier and crazier as he gets closer
and closer every point in the game every
place that he goes has Easter eggs for
various games like Dungeons and Dragons
is where he finds the first key but just
in this shot alone you see the classic
1960s Batmobile you see the Mach 5 racer
from speed racer you see the DeLorean as
he climbs into it like I said lots of
80s Easter eggs so they work in that van
Halen track this is Harley Quinn in
Deathstroke like I said Warner Brothers
IP so you have a lot of DC Comics
characters there's a little tiny Gandalf
here or twirling in the background of
the sky here you can see him holding his
staff this nerd Messiah James Halliday
is very clearly an analogue of Steve
Jobs who passed away around the time
that the book was released this is the
bike from akira they've been trying to
make a nakeeran movie for a long time
who knows if we'll ever see that you
have King Kong and then as we get
towards the very end of the trailer
that's when the Easter eggs get really
crazy and it's a little too fuzzy to
pick them all out specifically but these
actually look like the Battletoads if
you guys remember that game
that was so long ago here's Harlequin in
the Joker
here's your overwatch characters with
chun-li from Street Fighter you even
spot Duke Nukem in the background
there's a Gundam there's a Chucky that
goes full-on Yoda from Attack of the
Clones when he just starts jumping
around taking everybody out and it's
hard to tell this Iron Giant scene but
there might be a couple lightsabers in
the crowd there I don't know how
Lucasfilm would feel about that so they
probably tried to minimize any Star Wars
references but yeah probably my favorite
Easter eggs are Chucky in the Iron Giant
let me know in the comments though all
the Easter eggs you spotted that I
didn't include in the video and which
are your favorite but there are so many
it's probably gonna take three or four
times watching this to catch them all so
what will happen is is because the
embargo is up for Star Wars on Tuesday
that's when my non-spoilery review is
allowed to post there'll be a bunch of
other last Jedi videos happening this
next week and a bunch of comic book
stuff too so if you have any special
requests just leave them in the comments
below there's a new round of that IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll announce a
new winner when I post new last Jedi on
Monday so while you wait for everything
you can click here to rewatch that new
spider-man into the spider-verse trailer
and you can click here for brand new
last Jedi thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight